[Music]
let me stop you right here that young
and dumb [__] you black women throw out
as if it's supposed to get listen and
listen well women young and dumb is not
a get out of jail free card it doesn't
go woof and change the fact
you still have to carry that consequence
and men are not rushing up to be
stepfathers to 13 year olds I hit up
no no I agree with that I was having
this conversation with my mom the other
day I was like you should 100 tell
someone if they have kids because if you
didn't sign up to be a parent that's a
massive response if I was a man and this
as a woman you know as a woman I have
definitely got like I've been on a date
and they tell me they've got a kid
nice to meet you seemed lovely but I got
it it's kind of sad because I do feel
sorry for like single mothers and single
fathers but it's just like we didn't
sign up for that if if someone is
willing to play that role then 100 but a
lot of people unless they really really
love you and your kid because imagine
your kid's like an [__]
respect but no but respectively because
then you're now having to take
disrespect from a kid and you can't even
yours say anything back because it will
offend the mother or the father and it's
like it's a really weird how do you
parent when there's another parent
exactly because I'm like you're not mad
I used to play that to my mom's birthday
you're not my dad's shut up like and you
know as a man getting told by like a 13
year old it's like you know it's crazy
with custody
if a guy typically a guy sees this kid
what six days a month if the woman's
dating someone that man will have more
influence on the kid than the actual Dad
yeah and that's I do I do feel sorry for
fathers because that's like saying how
kind of way that I grew up like I didn't
really see my dad a lot and is it is
really upsetting but unfortunately I
don't think the system really works in a
lot of Dad's favors and I don't think if
you're if the father isn't a complete
just like deadbeat I think
everyone needs their father in their
life regardless male or female whatever
everyone needs their dad if they're safe
type of vibe because it's just it's not
nice was your dad
um did he try to get custody of you
um yeah and he wasn't able to uh no
because as well because of like the
country thing like being in the UK and
him being in the US so it's like it's
all yeah
okay yeah it was like a whole thing but
we're cool now we talk all the time now
literally go to Australia like it's it's
we worked out but I do say like I wish
we did grow up as a fan but guys I
forgot to put this forward I'm gonna go
back just re-watch this so they can see
I'm sorry guys black women throw out and
see if he's supposed to get listen and
listen well women young and dumb is not
a get out of jail free card it doesn't
go woof and change the fact
you still have to carry that consequence
and men are not rushing up to be
stepfathers to 13 year olds
what would be better is if you honestly
sat down and ask yourself what value can
I bring to a man and I know that what I
can well
all right what can what value what what
is it
what is it blunt
I can help him with this business very
[Music]
big what'd you say don't you think
that's what she like needs to hear
because even if she did have that
therapy session what if he spoke the
exact same way
did you get it because that's what she
came on for because if her outcome I
want to be married that's what she said
right you weren't here but earlier in
the call if that was the outcome she
wanted isn't it better to know where you
stand so you can pick the guys that will
watch you
yeah but it's just upset because a lot
of the time what men like to say and
kind of sometimes like women yourselves
is like you have to be a housewife to
get a husband and a lot of women
nowadays don't want to be Housewives and
I don't think you necessarily should
have to be a housewife to get a husband
again I think it should be equal parts
and some people should do this like if
if you don't cook maybe you can do this
if you don't do this I can do like
compromise that compromise can make and
break I don't I don't think you need to
be a housewife to get a husband I think
it depends on the outcomes you want in
terms of like I think babies I think the
best if you want the most children with
the man with the most amount of money
having housewife skills will get you
that outcome
some women don't want that life's about
choices and trade-offs yeah if you're
trying to play that game then 100 yeah
you're trying to blame on me then men
want to feel like they're like taking
like the motherly and what do you get
that from having housewife skills
working with kids like that's what women
also when they're from men and sometimes
we don't want mothers from not mothers
but we want someone like I would love if
a man kicks for me I'd be like oh my
because I work a lot like I've worked
more than like a lot of the guys I've
dated like I'm coming home time would
you prefer cook a home-cooked meal from
him or him taking you out to dinner to a
nice restaurant in London
because the restaurants are really cute
but then like if you cooked into it
it's okay it's okay I would say in
general though would you agree most
women want the restaurants yeah to go
out so so it's not as valued for the
same things where a guy doesn't want to
be taken out to dinner by a girl it's
like we're just not the same it doesn't
it's so hard because we're just like we
were different just the beings of like
male and female because you want with
completely different beings trying to
like coexist it's it's crazy so we're
not equal no I don't think we've ever
been equal but when you're saying like
you're a partner you do things yeah but
like that's why I say compromise because
like I can't necessarily cook but I
would try and learn to cook but it's
like okay but I can contribute elsewhere
what percent of women do you really
think can cook meals from scratch I
don't think as many nowadays because and
as well but I think that's all the thing
where back in the day you were taught in
school yeah and you did like food Tech
once like I only did again I'm 21 so I'm
like just finished school and stuff it's
like we only did cooking lessons for
about two three years and I was actually
really good at it I used to be able to
cook it but then after that is nothing
so what it wouldn't you say that men are
willing to compromise because most women
can't cook but compromise them what what
are they then giving us for that company
I mean I would say most men are pretty
handy if I need anything fixed around
here I can go to any guy here and just
be like can you fix this and they'll
figure it out and say most men are handy
um not that they can like build a house
or anything you know only a house right
now
um I would say protection I really
appreciate having a guy around because I
feel safer I would also say that men
um typically make more than women so
they usually bring in more money than
women because the average income is
around like 45 for men 35 for women
in the U.S I don't want to hear it it's
whatever the equivalent of that roughly
um so you already have money you have
protection you have
fixing things and I also would say
leadership if you appreciate men and
their ability to make decisions from a
more logical point of view I would say
those are all things that most men bring
to the table
where I don't think most women are
nurturing which is something we're
supposed to be do you think so I think
we all but I think you get you nudge it
to a point where again you get a hurt
and say that because I think I think a
lot of women want to be feminine but
cannot be feminine without yeah I do
think they start off nurturing you're
right but I don't I think that again
since the majority of women have been
hurt before and are not virgins and are
not waiting for marriage and have
typically had a [__] past they come in
jaded and not as nurturing because you
kind of make for the men in the future
pay for what you did in the past yeah
and I think there's maybe one guy that
got the feminine version of you or
whoever it was and there's 10 guys that
didn't yeah but yeah that's the and
that's the end with thing that like yeah
because even guys would be like get
heartbroken because no one let's be
certain like no one when they're young
goes into a relationship thinking I'm
gonna be a [__] girl I'm gonna be a [__]
boy everyone wants that like cute high
school like love is just like really
really nice it's not honeymoon
I think that's what everyone wants but
everyone's so scared of hurting each
other that it's just like no one's
really really winning and so it's just
like how do we do you think women are
afraid of hurting men when half of women
have admitted to going on dates for food
that's crazy that's it that's that I
think that is really mean I don't really
like women who do that because it's like
you then can't complain when they say
this when we're feeding in but you would
agree that women they're not afraid of
hurting men because certain women yeah
half at least okay yeah okay wait let's
let me uh plant
um into planting my own garden so
I can definitely plan um into
um improving my Elegance with
um
just self-improvement and working on you
see you're gonna start to notice this
women always say what they bring to the
tables what they want from men so she
wants a man that's into self-improvement
so she says self-improvement so
oftentimes when you hear women describe
what they want it's really what they
want
Elephant Man at 35 years old we're 35
years old here's what you've told me
I can help him with his business the
respect man
um and I mean no disrespect but 20 to 30
percent of people own businesses what
about the 70 to 80 percent of men who
don't own them that means that doesn't
matter
that means nothing to the average man
then the next thing you said I can plant
man that means nothing to most people
because we go to grocery stores
then you say self-improvement
I gave you a shot at saying what you
have to offer to men and you said
nothing that we value
what do you buy what do you book a
session book a session
nope nope nope nope I'm done I've tried
to go around but this has happened the
ODU ladies get the more you get set in
your ways book a session because I don't
want to do this in public man because
you seem like a sweet woman but you
don't but you're not getting it you're
being so mean I'm not being don't tell
me I'm being mean
I'm about to be mean I get tired of you
broads telling me I'm being mean because
you cannot handle a goddamn truth you
called my show on the day the training
was supposed to be here and I honored
the call and sat here and tried to help
you and I'm telling you telling me I'm
being mean the [__] out of my phone
she didn't know she was about to be a
viral sensation
oh
so what'd you guys think Kevin Samuels
you can take off the headphones we're
done with the I think not everyone would
be able to take his criticism because of
how much it triggers whatever
he's directing his opinions at mm-hmm
it's very hard pill to swallow where
we've come in society is like it's it's
what Kevin Samuel represents is
traditional households traditional
relationships I feel like we have
strayed way way past that yeah what do
you think works better
modern or traditional typically
from what I've seen traditional usually
works out and but again it's a hard pill
to swallow people don't unfortunately
want to hear the truth but gotta play
the game man it is it is what it is you
make your bed and I'm gonna Read Super
chats real quick
um
we have 838 people watching in the chat
um it seems like most women want to mail
clone of themselves also guys they've
been calling my followers brokies
so I appreciate the super chats because
I'm tired of them I'm tired of these
these women not them
these women these women saying saying
that you guys are broken you know damn
well you're not broke guys are dumb try
this after a few drinks oh they're
saying he still would you just gotta get
him drunk no
uh that would be how can you be logical
that would be me abusing him yeah that
wouldn't be like yeah you know what I'm
saying you know then I'm just playing
the sound okay
wait I want to go to the Super Chat for
Canada
they're not doing
her in a supers there we go
all right
um it seems like my guys aren't dumb and
marriage do women want peace or do they
want to be right all the time
chick has yet to give a straight answer
I finally disagree with pearl she's cute
with the hairstyle and I'm not a simp oh
look at they said keep it they said keep
it uh the blonde uh this chick has yet
to get a straight answer bro oh wait no
no the
the blonde has to they're disagreeing
the blonde has to go young lady men
don't like it uh Pearl I hope you saw
that Viral Twitter post from the newly
married woman who said her husband is a
virgin and she has to go oh to God to
erase the memory of all the men she had
slept with why would a 30 to 40 year old
man who makes good money risks trying to
impregnate a 30-plus young woman when he
gets plenty of opportunity from women in
their 20s silent sandwiches sex
um happy sammy wait until you show up
wait until they show you their serious
to give up value yourselves if you don't
value you they won't either modesty
agreeable think Doug if you navigate
life like a single woman no one is going
to stop you ladies no man is going to
break down your walls or understand your
past traumas
um by the way if green if green eyes
girls Cooks bingos I accept her as a
true chef and um in the in U.S I'm a
Brokey in Poland I'm middle class take
care girls Isaac a key that opens many
locks is a master a lock that open as
many keys is useless Lawrence why would
they date a man would they date a man
that went through a gay phase
um yes you would yes or no no thank you
I think yeah I wouldn't either
Pearl is converting one hoe at a time
sorry guys women
um they also often need social approved
before they're interested in a man
that's why a man with a high body count
is not the same as a woman with high
body count Pearl Andrew huberman and
Sarah go something about birth control
Pearl pull up techman study for sex
partners in marriage um Janome you know
global warming is bad when there are
more whales on land than in the water
what happened to your girl
pearls show the lovely ladies Texas Jeff
younger cases Lawrence as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible